So you know how a Chinese is just picture writing.
There's more to this story,
like all of the world's earliest writing systems.
Chinese characters start out as symbols that Stanford words,
a rice patty,
a person,
a treat please,
our logo graphs and they let you depict specific language pieces to write what
you mean.
But instead of requiring different characters for every word,
the handy rebus principle lets you write other things that sound like the lower
graph to write what you say.
Sure you could use the rebus sounds like principal to write any sound in your
language,
but please consider this symbol and answer the question that follows.
Does it mean son soon son or sewn?
Oh my.
Did free bus riding.
Get you into a bit of trouble here.
When we see this character,
we could read it as a plain old logo graph according to its meaning or any of
these rebus ways following gets pronunciation.
Which one should you choose to think a bit outside of the jade box here and take
the lead of this hand scratch his solution is elegant.
Don't choose one.
Use both systems together.
What's that?
Behind his back.
Is that a ho?
Yeah.
Major moments in the history of writing.
So here's the logo graph for horse,
but it also sounds the same as the word for aunt said.
The rebus principle lets us write them both with the same glyphs.
Confusing,
not if you add the logo graph for insect next to the stound delight character.
This says it's pronounced like horse,
which it is,
but that it's meaning has something to do with insect.
You don't read the extra character.
It's a meaning hint determining how to read the sound character.
So it's called [inaudible]
terminated.
One more mandarin example.
This loga graph means moon,
which happens to be pronounced UAA using rebus writing.
Yay.
Awesome means amputate your feet.
Incidentally,
the word key is pronounced the same way.
Same problem,
but nothing.
A couple determinative can't fix.
Add the determinative for metal to this character at knife to that one.
And let's leave the moon B because that's already what it means here.
Again,
the sounds like reading of the character gives you it's phonetic component.
This extra Logograph clues you into its meaning.
It's semantic component together.
They form a unit,
a whole character with a clear meaning and a clear pronunciation determinative
is are very common in Chinese characters,
natively called Han Carrie.
In fact,
since they hint at the characters route,
meaning it's Radix Han determinative get called radicals.
Bringing back the characters sun.
It can be pronounced many ways,
truth,
but at a determinative,
yeah,
a silent helper character and you can quickly narrow down.
It's meaning these extra avoid ambiguous readings.
Which one is the sun in the sky,
which is a father son,
which one means soon too easy.
There's something else to learn from this quiet scribe.
He's using radicals to clean up some ambiguity,
but even he knows that context matters.
He won't spell everything out for you every time.
Sometimes this character means for as in this is for you.
Other Times it's the verb supply.
He's balancing this tension in the history of writing between what's easy on the
reader,
who needs more information to interpret the words versus what's easy on the
writer,
who typically knows what he means when he's writing it.
Plus hand cramps.
The choice of leaving in or leaving out.
Helpful information isn't simply about clarity and laziness.
It's a static throughout the history of Chinese calligraphy from Oracle loans to
the rough cursive script.
Stylistic choices are made not just semantic and phonetic choices.
Seeing through the calligraphers eyes,
you can find in the history of writing not only a vision of what words and
sounds look like,
but where words and sounds go and where they stop.
When it comes to aesthetic choices and Han characters,
none is more fundamental than the decision to arrange character components in
blocks.
Bonus note,
this is definitely not the only time in history that writing gets organized in
blocks.
So this radical sits on top of this phonetic component in a block making up one
whole character.
The character for flour,
the idiographic man plus tree,
a man leaning against a tree has two components sitting side by side in a block
and they're the character for rest.
And here's one tree and its own block,
two trees,
meaning woods and three trees for forest.
Aesthetics aside,
what would happen if we took,
this sounds like principal a step further and made writing about this sounds,
isn't that a better solution to our soon son sown son problem and one that
doesn't make us memorize tons of characters.